le placage la passe le tir au pied le
rugby n'a plus de secret pour ces jeunes
habitants de Saint-Pierre-des-Corps qui
ont profité d'une animation organisée
par le club ussp rugby devant la gare
TGV militaire 1 praticable une
découverte pour révéler des vocations
lors de cet événement rugby-sitter c'est
sans nom Faustine du nom
ce n'est pas le départ d'un train mais
bien le coup d'envoi d'un match de rugby
sur le parvis de la gare de
Saint-Pierre-des-Corps le club US ESP
rugby Renou pour la première fois depuis
le covid avec le rugby cité vous avez
amené vos enfants à cette journée pour
découvrir ce qui était le rugby en fait
on regarde enfin on regarde pas trop à
la télé mes enfants font du basket ça
fait du bien ça leur permet de divertir
d'échanger un peu d'air match sur
terrain réduit structure gonflable
parcours d'obstacles ou plots à faire
tomber l'événement propose de nombreuses
activités autour du rugby
je vais faire une course contre
ça ça amène tout ce qui est jeu au pied
la passe le fait de marquer le fait
d'avancer le fait de jouer en équipe là
avec ce jeu là et donc c'est tout ce que
le rugby un petit peu c'est tout ce
qu'il y a dans le rugby en fait une
équipe d'instructeurs du club local et
de l'antenne rugby Touraine du
département en cadre les activités de
jeunes licencie sont aussi venus prêter
main forte j'aime bien en tout cas
enchaîner le rugby parce que c'est un
peu ma passion quand même une passion
transmise espère l'USS et rugby en tout
cas les leçons semblent faire leur petit
effet car les enfants assimilent déjà
les règles de base on a une balle et en
fait on doit essayer de marquer on peut
plaquer des gens aussi on peut marquer
on peut esquiver la balle faire faire du
sport aux enfants surtout c'est
l'objectif numéro un après forcément
leur faire faire du rugby et qu'ils
aiment le rugby et ensuite forcément
aussi que on attend qu'il y en ait
quelques-uns qui viennent dans notre
club partagé
partagé tous ces beaux moments que notre
sport nous offre prochain rendez-vous du
rugby cité le 31 mai place des
cosmonautes à Saint-Pierre-des-Corps